so
when is the real wedding we don't know
yet we're just you know living our best
lives fast forward one month and
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are officially living their best lives
in italy to officially tie the knot now
they've had plenty of practice but this
weekend is the official italian blowout
bash the couple and quartz kids mason
penelope and rayne touched down friday
in portofino italy for what will be
their third wedding celebration but
before they say i do one more time they
were spotted on a boat taking in the
italian coast
it was beautiful amazing
no pre-wedding jitters for court she
looks relaxed sporting merch from her
hubby's band to blink 182 while travis
soaks in the sun shirtless and as any
couple would do while visiting italy
especially kravis they took a moment to
engage in some pre-wedding pda
you'll recall courtney and travis are
already legally married thanks to an
intimate courthouse ceremony in santa
barbara california last sunday a source
opened up to et about the small affair
saying everyone in courtney's family was
busy on sunday and it was so last minute
they decided to have only courtney's
grandma mj from her side and travis's
dad from his side for the santa barbara
wedding the source added that travis has
grandma's stamp of approval quote mj was
so happy and thinks courtney and travis
are truly a match and in love and before
they made things legally official there
was the post grammy unofficial vegas
warm-up i got a call that a celebrity
wanted to get married they didn't tell
me who it was they just said a celebrity
and uh we need elvis they were just
falling in love they were just kissing
and
laughing and they're in love
and they're just smiling and they're
left happy
and with the practice wedding and the
official nuptials out of the way the
only thing left to do is party as for
what to expect well a source tells e.t
courtney's big wedding will have the
entire family there and be so over the
top she is so excited it will be a
bigger moment with all her sisters
family friends and travis's family and
friends in italy they're looking forward
to bringing their fun funky families
together courtney's family is over the
moon excited for her
i love you
[Music]
and when the couple returns stateside to
officially begin their lives together as
husband and wife one thing's for sure
courtney will be treated to a lifetime
of matcha amy what are you doing
drinking
this matcha that you made me your famous
matcha
i actually make the best matcha way
better than the best any matcha place in
l.a alfred's cha-cha matcha my matcha is
actually it is
[Music]